good morning believe nation today's
messages choose who you listen to open
to you Gabrielle Union at my career I
was named the next it girl and you're
like well you know I think we should you
know I should really believe this you
know and then you read your the worst
thing ever you should never leave the
house and you're like that we should
throw that out and eventually you just
kind of get to a place where they kind
of cancel each other out you're gonna
hear the naysayers and the people who
think you suck and they're gonna be the
people who think you're the second
coming of you know pockets but like it's
usually somewhere in the middle if you
believe all your your your praise
there's nowhere to go they're not gonna
grow and if you believe you know every
negative thing about you you're not
gonna get out of bed so I try to be
reasonable people whose opinion I
respect I listen you need to be really
careful who you listen to
you've got this big dream you've got
these big ambitions you want to make
your mark you want to do your thing and
often that's scary you know if it
involves doing something you've never
done before that could be quite scary
and when people tell you that you can't
do it when people tell you that you suck
when people tell you said we're gonna
work out a lot of times that's really
hard to hear because you are doubting
yourself and when you hear that from
other people that just compounds the
doubt it makes you wonder can I actually
go and do this thing and so choosing who
you listen to it really really important
some people will pour rain on your
parade because of jealous because maybe
they've taken their shot at following
their dreams and it didn't work out and
so now nobody around them can have
success either nobody else is allowed to
go off and be an entrepreneur and chase
their dreams because they tried it and
it didn't work out and so nobody else
can have it life sucks and they're going
to drag everybody down in the hole with
them that's a lot of people others may
rain on your parade because they
actually love you they just don't see
what you see you know your parents may
think that it's not a great idea or your
guidance counselor or your friends may
not think that what you're doing is fee
visible because in their world nobody's
ever done it because they haven't done
it and your parents may be thinking
success equals this because that's what
success is for them because that's the
path that they took and so they may be
raining on your parade but it's out of
love a sign of the jealousy at the end
of the day they want to see you become
successful they just have a different
definition of success and they don't
want to see you go through pain and hurt
and struggle and woes and maybe not
reaching your goal and then there are
other people who give you the perfect
advice exactly what you need exactly at
the right time that you need it and so
really paying attention to who has given
you this advice and not trying to have
an emotional reaction to it but look at
that person say has this person done
what I want to do does this person have
the expertise to give me the advice that
I meet because if somebody is telling
you that your idea sucks I will never
work out and they haven't done what you
are trying to do then their advice is
meaningless to you if anything you
should do the opposite why are you
taking advice from someone who hasn't
done what you want to do you cannot let
their limited mindset prevent you from
being great and it doesn't mean you need
to attack them it doesn't mean you need
to say you don't know what you're
talking about
you have a limited mindset you've never
gone out and achieve your dreams you
don't have to hurt them back but you
also don't have to react to the
information they're giving you treat
them like a child treat them like a
puppy treat them like a baby they can't
help it they're negative it made me have
a jealousy it may be out of love but
either way you wouldn't take advice from
a baby and if you can defuse that in
your head if you can understand that
these people have not done what you're
trying to do and not listen to their
advice and not listen to their doubts
and still know that you need to get this
done it maybe doesn't work out maybe you
don't hit that dream maybe you don't get
your goals but you still need to know
because you would rather fail and at
least know then live the rest of your
life uncertain
and then regret wishing you had gave
more to the cause if you're growing food
work stop planning stop thinking with
the head stop using your logic all the
time with all the big decisions make
them with the heart so the question fate
today is I'm curious who has given you
the best advice for your business and
what was it leave in the comments below
I'm super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Stefan
Pataki thank you so much man for picking
up a copy of my book your one-word
really really really means a lot to me
and I hope that you're enjoying the read
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning for another
shot events beso
[Music]
the only time in the last couple of
years that I knew as soon as we finished
a song that it was sort of a like I hate
to say that game-changer but it that it
was sort of a next-level situation was
when I finished shake it off and but I
wanted me I wanted to be sure so I that
was the very end of the recording
process
I finished shake it off and I knew I was
done with the record and I flew back to
Nashville had a bunch of label people
who I trust and a bunch of management
who I trust and my mom and dad sit in my
parents living room and I played them
the full record and I didn't tell them
anything about how I thought I had
written the first single I didn't tell
them anything like you gotta listen like
listen for track eight shake it off is
the one I'm telling you but when that
song came on and halfway through all of
them look at me and go this is the one
it was such a validating feeling because
I thought I knew and I was so sure I
knew and then it turned out I did know